the way the influence people all over
the globe is changing and the single
word I would describe for that is on
ramps you we need as many on ramps as
possible and those on ramps need to be
as diverse as possible so if you're in
the middle of the country and you happen
to love beaches and if you would ask 100
million people in the US who loves the
beach you know most people would put
their hand up how many of you want to
actually go out and do a beach cleanup
15 people would put their hands up so in
order to kind of span that chasm you
need lots of different on ramps we had
an event in New York City last week for
society art collectors very specific on
ramp for a very specific niche we're
going to launch an initiative called
where's your beach which is essentially
myspace myspace meets craigslist meets
surfrider foundation so it's a regional
regionally based social network around
coastal areas another on-ramp so
organizations need as many on ramps as
possible if they're going to reach
different people different types of
organizations cultures etc
you